[Music]
thank you
hey everybody welcome back to the what
podcast this is a podcast that we
started in 2018
originally to talk about the Bonnaroo
Music and Arts Festival and it has grown
into much much more it's a music about
festivals in general and music in
general when we want to plus we kind of
talk about whatever else we want to I'm
Barry that's Lord taco
you'll notice again this week not with
us is uh
my co-host and co-founder along with uh
Russ Lord taco and I
um Brad Steiner I I need to I need to
come clean I guess
Taco last week you know I kind of said
he was busy
um
the truth is Brad's kind of been on a
hunger strike ever since he made that
List of Demands what was it four weeks
ago about who he wanted oh that's right
yeah he made that List of Demands back
in August 24th of who he wanted to see
at uh next year's Bonnaroo uh Chief
among them Rage Against the Machine and
uh the wild hearts got a whole list and
he's been on this hunger strike
I don't think he's had any red meat
scent I'm pretty sure he's not eating
any red meat
pretty sure he's not in any red meat yet
um let's make in those demands yeah he's
he's waiting on a response he wants he
wants to be heard and
he's weak how he's yeah he's weakened
anyway he's not with us but uh as we
told you last week in talking with Matt
Carney
that we uh Russ and I both attended the
Moon River Festival here in Chattanooga
it got rained out on Sunday and they
were able to uh pretty quickly pivot and
come put together a
impromptu concert at Memorial our
Memorial Auditorium here in Chattanooga
in about
depending on how when you want to start
counting it was either four and a half
hours or two and a half hours I think
the first phone call went out about four
or four Thirty the
but that original even four and a half
hours is got to be a record as far as
yeah starting from scratch and then
getting a full production team together
and throw on a concert yeah that first
phone call just kind of said hey can you
guys start talking about it and they did
in about six I think they decided wasn't
gonna happen because it looked like it
was going to clear up and then three
minutes later it was happening so that's
where the two and a half hours comes
yeah and you uh you know when you really
think about it it's not just unlocking
the doors and saying here you go you
know they had um ushers they had
security they had you know everybody uh
food vendors everybody that would
normally be there for a fully planned
show they just showed up out of nowhere
and uh it's it's a lot of behind the
scenes to make that happen and it was
pretty neat to hear them talk about how
this all came together so quickly yeah
and I think another really really valid
point that they make and you're gonna
hear the the interviews Russ and I I I
if you don't know this show right Russ
is his real name we call him Lord Taco I
go back and forth so if that confuses
you I'm I apologize
um but you'll hear we talk with
and let me set this up real quick if I
can this is we started this show in 2018
Brad Steiner and I did with with Russ
Russ is the web designer the technical
guy the producer he's the one that makes
it all work uh Brad and I are typically
on camera lately because we've gone
through YouTube Russ because I mean look
at that Putnam
I mean you gotta have that fun I'm on
camera right so he's been joining us
um but we started it
um I work I have for
35 36 years at the Chattanooga Times
Free Press is a entertainment reporter
Brad is a radio guy he's done it for 21
years 22 years something like just about
yeah that sounds about right yeah and so
we've been going to Bonnaroo since
almost the beginning 16 years
um and we we noticed that throughout the
year even when you know
August and whatever January February we
were talking about it
um and we figured there were probably
other people doing the same we were
fascinated by the logistics of it we
love the inside Baseball part of it
and so we kind of half jokingly said we
should do a podcast for about two or
three months leading up to the 2018 one
and we've been doing it ever since we
love the inside baseball stuff is the
yes is my long way around here right you
and Brad uh conceived and founded the
show and then and just invited me if I
could help out with some of the website
and technical stuff and I said sure I
said uh you know and I got a free
battery ticket of it and I thought
that'd be it yeah um
I didn't think we'd still be doing it
five years later I didn't think I would
end up on the show right quite frankly
yeah well it works and and it works out
yeah so
anyway I mean go ahead we did find
there's a lot more to talk about than
just the bands and just the artists
that's right just the lineup and so Russ
we have a website the what podcast.com
you can look at all of the artists and
Industry people that we've had as gas
and and when I look at it I'm stunned I
mean it's it's been a lot of fun and and
a real learning
I mean from Ashley Capps AC
entertainment the founder founder of AC
entertainment and co-founder of Bonnaroo
um has been a guest Jeff Quay it's quite
a list yeah impressive it's it's yeah
we've had
promoters radio people I mean it's Ed
O'Brien Radiohead
um
uh Briston moroney is among our
favorites we've just had a bunch you can
look at the list and and I say that just
in case you're new to the show you know
you're wondering who these two guys are
and who cares
um but it's the inside Baseball part
that I really wanted to bring up because
that's kind of really what we got into
with this episode
I mean it's it's way inside baseball
um
we talked with Ted heinek president of
AC entertainment currently uh Drew
Holcomb co-founder of the Moon River
Festival we talked with Nick Wilkinson
and Courtney Keane and Sam Fort they're
the folks over at Memorial
Auditorium that made it happen on Sunday
and I want to point out you know that
sounds like it's Chattanooga Centric but
I think it was should be interesting or
could be interesting to anybody anywhere
because
you know you all have theaters in your
hometown and there's festivals
everywhere and uh
not saying they can all happen like this
I'm not saying they I'm not saying that
they could even do it again here
the Stars lined up
for them like you said to be able to
it's not just opening the door and
turning on the lights
they had 18 bartenders show up I mean
think about that on a Sunday who got the
call after six o'clock
and the other thing I was going to say
and uh it comes up in the in the
interview is it's a heck of a risk for
the artist
I mean they didn't show up with all
their production and their own sound guy
they didn't even get to do sound checks
so I mean yeah think about that
the last thing they want to do is is
suck basically I mean I don't know how
to put it
yes because the the pr from that would
be worse than a cancellation yeah
exactly I didn't know he sounded that
bad or whatever you know he didn't play
my favorite song or whatever I mean
think about it yeah there's a lot that
could have gone wrong that's right
and they and they also we we pointed out
a little bit I think we don't think we
made such a big point in this particular
set of interviews because I think I
added some of it out but
um
the seat I got to quit doing that I did
that on the last show I'm sorry I don't
know why I'm Russ and I were laughing
it's not like my dentures were falling
out because I don't have Dentures so
I'll try to quit doing that
but
C3 and AC and Drew and Live Nation
basically
are going to refund
uh people's money if you bought two day
tickets they're going to refund half and
that also includes your fees if you
bought one day Sunday tickets they're
going to refund that which is pretty
remarkable and and that I think that's
what really sort of I don't know is the
two things it was the Sunday show
and the refund because we got the refund
notice first right yes and I didn't
expect that at all no they don't have to
do that anyone did no that's a that's a
big shout out to C3 and Live Nation who
can make that sort of thing happen
um
but
as part of our show you know when
Bonnaroo canceled uh last year after the
hurricane came through uh there was a
lot of social media chatter that people
didn't get their refunds for months and
months and months and so there wasn't a
lot of communication so they kind of
took a a PR hit
this is essentially the same folks not I
mean Drew Holcomb is is different but
it's essentially many of the same folks
that do Bonnaroo
and um quite honestly they learned a
lesson right I mean obviously I think so
yeah and you know we've been
somewhat critical over the last few
years I mean if there's something that
needs to be pointed out that could go
better we've pointed it out so that's
right and then on the flip side when
something goes very well and they do
something great we want to highlight
that yeah and talk about it and I think
that's what this is
um
You're Going to Hear I mean Brad has
said many many times on this show that
we you know while we're
um I mean I'm a newspaper journalist
he's a radio guy this is a podcast we
can be critical but we're also big big
fans
we love
music festivals and and that sort of
thing so
we try to straddle that line I guess so
if there's uh moments of bloviating
or or going too far you know forgive us
but we're fans but also I think we try
to ask good questions and uh if we don't
know the answer we try to go to the
source
and I really think that's what we did
here
so I'm I'm glad we did it
I mean kudos to them I mean I woke up
Monday morning and thought this is a
good story I wanna I wanna I wanna talk
about this and so I reached out to Ted
heinig who I expected it you know for
whatever reason
the legitimately say I I can't can't do
it now you know gotta run through this
this person and that person and
we were on the phone with him Andrew
Holcomb an hour and 15 minutes later
that about right yeah it came together
very quick yeah surprising it usually
doesn't go that fast no it does not
it's usually a lot of back and forth and
well when can you do it and yeah let me
get it through this guy yeah and uh
Sue Sue uh a PR person was on an
airplane and made it happen and uh thank
you to her thank you to this to Ted and
Drew and then the next day similar we
were on the phone with the folks over at
Memorial on a zoom call so you're going
to see two Zoom calls and we I tried to
edit between the two so if there's if
it's not the slick as production you
know again we tried to do it as quickly
as we could because yeah I mean we're
scrambling too to get this content out
because we think it's important yeah and
um honestly that's why Brad is is not
here he's got a lot going on where he is
uh with his work but uh yeah taco and I
wanted to get it done and thank you I
mean you jumped on there too
for both of those Zoom calls and I'm
glad you did
um me too and it was kind of uh it was a
high point because we left Sunday you
know we had three band interviews
scheduled Sunday that's right and you
know when when the word came down that
you know this isn't going to happen I
was a little disappointed that we had
stuff that we could talk about and
didn't get to do it and then it turned
out that we actually had did have a lot
to talk about
yeah we were able to move quickly and
get this out we were lined up to talk
the band from Band of Horses and Sammy
Ray and uh wilderado folks and we were
very excited about it and you know not
trying to complain it happens and and so
this is the point of this conversation
is we go it's a deep dive with Ted and
Drew what was going through their minds
why they canceled uh the reasons behind
it
you know the whole almost a Blow by blow
kind of thing starting at about what 215
um that was interesting and then
and then the folks from the Tivoli
foundations which runs Memorial uh jump
in and and the series of events for why
that worked is uh is pretty fascinating
so I think it has a little bit of
everything it has a behind the curtains
kind of what's it like to run an event
like this what's it like to make these
kinds of decisions
and just the honestly the dumb luck of
everything that fell into place
from guys like Leon Bridges showing up
and borrowing someone else's guitar uh
yeah it's such a great detail right
it is and there's so many things that
they talk about that if one thing had
gone wrong it would have like right
pulled the thread out and unraveled and
the bottom would have fell and out it
wouldn't have happened that's a great
way to put it that's exactly right
together yeah one yeah and there was a
lot of those one things that that could
have killed this whole idea I'm glad you
mentioned that too because one thing we
didn't mention in the interview and
um even in in last week's show that I
wanted to point out that that we that we
didn't talk about but we didn't miss
uh these kinds of things have happened
elsewhere I mean Bonnaroo last year when
the hurricane hit we had many ruse we
had many events you and I you were
involved in two of them maybe three
uh three at this point yeah
I mean it happens where people pivot
they rally they set up a stage in a
sound system somewhere else I don't want
to I I don't want to you know dismiss
that
um
it happens all the time you know even
even on Sunday Drew and Ellie Holcomb
went out into a crowd with a guitar and
played for an hour
JP sax did the same I mean that happens
and that I don't mean to dismiss that
this is a little bit different because
we're talking about a a municipal
building a City Auditorium
um that holds 3 000 people
four five five or six
artists that were scheduled to play that
Sunday showed up and did a
any concert and this wasn't just yeah it
wasn't just people just showing up and
playing a guitar there was there was a
little bit more a little bit bigger than
that but again that's not too diminish
in any way the mini ruse that happened I
mean you know our friends Darla I mean
Charlotte and Daniel
with the rubus and and Lindsay and uh
all those people that did that that huge
Minnie rude just outside the Manchester
area and even in Manchester I know the
the Bonnaroo folks were
were instrumental in you know providing
what a generator and maybe some staging
so I mean
yeah that's another example of stuff
thrown to get there at the last minute
and it all comes together yeah um so
it's not a president at all and like I
said I don't want to diminish those
happening and and I think Drew even
mentions Brandy Carlisle uh did similar
at a at another Festival so it it
happened this was just a
just an on
I don't know not unbelievable but uh
unusual
circum set of circumstances and uh
it just it fascinated you and me so we
wanted to talk about it and they were
willing to jump on the phone in the zoom
and talk to us about it so
yeah and you can tell by their uh
conversation that they were just as
excited to pull this off as we were to
see it happen that's a great Point yeah
they're all fans and
you know they work in it but they're
also uh you know just as much excited
about live music and shows and stuff as
we are so yeah it's neat that they could
they could pull it all off I would I I
talked with Ted heinek
uh yesterday I think so two days after
we did the initial interview and we were
just kind of talking about it again and
rehashing and I said you know I'll put
it this way maybe the the thing that
sums it up for me is Sam uh who is the
technical basically the production guy
at Memorial who was on vacation and uh
was not supposed to be back until Monday
and just happened to be in town on
Sunday and uh his his comment was
it was the most exciting thing I've been
a part of and I would have been mad had
I missed it
that's kind of what sums it up so yeah
and who could say that about their job
that I would have been mad if I had
missed some work working on a Sunday
night when I should have been yeah
asleep or fishing or whatever
oh that's a good point yeah so it's
about a about a 25 minute it's not
hopefully not too too long and I hope
you guys will watch it because I have a
feeling it's something we're going to be
talking about and referencing and and
all of that for future
um events and and festivals so uh I
guess uh without any more here we go
[Music]
well let me go ahead and set things up
if I can uh for you know first of all
thank you both uh for for joining us and
uh taco and I were there Saturday uh we
got to interview wild rivers and um uh
Matt
Carney and then I I was there Sunday
until I had to evacuate but yeah I saw I
saw Maggie Rose and then some of Sammy
Ray
so yeah and I I wanted to uh I I got to
hug and howdy with Ted Drew we never got
to actually speak but I did want to
commend you on your three-legged race
skills
yeah sorry that my my son's uh backstage
birthday party was right in the middle
of your wild room oh it's awesome man I
listened it was great it makes it it's
perfect it's so great and uh I had
forgotten that your son was born four
years ago this weekend so I mean that
was makes it even
even better but uh so for people
listening and and I don't know how this
show is going to work out because like
like what you guys did during Moon River
we've we're sort of uh adapting uh I
just think what you guys did was so
amazing
um that we wanted to talk about it so
I reached out to uh people and they made
it happen very very quickly so that's
why we're talking so we'll jump in but
yeah I'd like I'd just like to start
because
I just think Drew deserves so much of
the credit here for coming up with the
idea to have an amazing show of Memorial
um
just it took uh it took what was a a
really tough day and and turned it into
something
that that for sure is a Moon River
highlight for the rest of my life I was
there Ted at Bonnaroo when they emptied
the site what four or five years ago
um that's a a unique situation where you
can have 80 000 people literally go back
to their cars and their tents kind of
hunker down and then clear everything
and then bring them all back
uh I was there at four castle and I
think 18 or 19. with Sam Smith when he
was on stage and the Gus NATO came up
I've never seen a storm like that
I had to clear the site and you guys had
to adapt and get everything ready for
Sunday which you did
um but this weekend on Sunday you had to
clear the site looked like everything
was maybe gonna get going back around
six
uh then 6 15 6 30 we get the notice that
everything is canceled for the night
hour later I get a phone call from Nick
Wilkinson over at the Tivoli Foundation
said hey I think we're going to put this
concert on at Memorial Auditorium I'll
know more in about five minutes well the
actual first call
was around probably it's probably about
the same time he called you Sam what
time was that about three
or four
I'll look at my phone here um like four
Thirty
yeah I was actually I was getting ready
to go to a Moon River
um I was having dinner with my wife we
had we had no kids we were going to try
to have a nice kind of relaxing lunch
and the rain came and then
um I you know I just just missed it like
oh well they'll be fine this will blow
right over we'll be good and then uh got
a call from Ted
it's probably the same time Sam did and
I realized wait something's happening
here
um they're way too busy to be bothered
you know with me right now and and then
obviously he said hey
uh would it be possible if we had to
somehow make something happen here you
know if we could possibly move it to
Memorial Auditorium would you guys be
willing to do that and I said sure we'll
figure it out don't know exactly how
that'll work does that set the stage am
I missing I mean that's kind of the very
very Basics now what we want to do is
how did that happen because it doesn't
just happen uh you know it's not like
the old uh
the old cartoons or whatever where
somebody says hey I've got a barn let's
let's go throw a show stuff has to move
stuff has to happen so if you guys don't
mind take us through how that happened
yesterday taking me to roll first
yeah why do you take it you take the fun
stuff Drew and then I'll handle the
unfun stuff
[Laughter]
yeah Ted could go into sort of the
bigger decisions about what happened
with the festival
um but around five o'clock
that cell was on top of the festival or
leaving the first cell second cell I
can't remember which one it was there's
some there's a couple of them but we got
we we were getting rained on really hard
and then it stopped and there was
obviously a lot of conversation
happening about what that storm had done
to the site um
and so there was some chatter about
whether or not we would be able to go on
and in the meantime Ellie and I ran out
there were tons of people out sort of by
the gate and so Ellie and I went out
there with just a guitar
played for about an hour just for all
the people who were standing there
waiting to get information I literally
while playing I had no idea what was
gonna
sort of transpire so as soon as I got
off
as soon as I went back inside the green
room area the artist area I got word
that
um we were canceling
and previous to going out there and
doing that I had sort of floated an idea
to my manager Paul and to Brian Benson
or another one of our partners who
wanted Ted's folks um hey worst case
here Kim is like it's more is the
Memorial Auditorium open can we just
throw an acoustic show if the worst case
happens here and it was kind of said
honestly a little bit in just not I mean
because I just at that point was pretty
confident we were going to be able to
re-re start I know Sam called me I
thought he was joking because I knew he
had just gotten back from his trip so I
was like oh you this is a joke
um so I get off you know fast forward an
hour hour and 20 minutes later I get off
I get word that we're gonna have to
cancel
and um Brian comes into my dressing room
he's like were you serious the about
helping put this thing together and I
said yeah absolutely I mean
I want to try to do something you know
um a lot of a lot of frustrated people
it's you know you can't control the
weather obviously but also there's all
these you know
the memorial doesn't hold as many people
are at the festival we are getting
worried a lot of people had left for the
day just because of the forecast and you
know so
just thought maybe we can try to throw
something together here we send
immediate word out to all the managers
of the artists who were on site for the
day and sort of got a head count and the
first head we got was Local Natives were
immediately in Sammy Ray said she would
like to do it JP said yes and as a
matter of fact he had already gone out
to play as well out in the parking lot
for people and
um I'm glad you mentioned that because I
saw that too that's pretty cool yeah it
was really sweet and then we were still
waiting for from from other acts and
there's obviously like you know when
you're putting on a festival like bands
and stuff it's really complicated
because people have a show and there's a
reason why production and changeover
takes long because you got it takes a
long time to sound check and and so I
just want to like throw a huge shout out
to the artists who are willing to do
this because they knew they were walking
into a dumpster fire of a of like you
know a last minute throw and go not the
way you want to sound not the way you
want to look
not the scenario that's a dream but also
like real you know also taking advantage
of the fact that hey these people love
this music and a lot of them travel here
to play and Local Natives especially
they were so great because this was
going to be their last show of the year
so to do what they did is a big big
um
what's the word risk is one word for
them yeah you know the last thing they
want to do is put on a bad show and have
people yeah yeah sounded bad you know
yeah I think it was risky on everybody's
part you know like
there's a lot of moving variables there
as far as you know this the quality of
the sound you know people are using
there were some guitars that people had
never played before that were just
brought in because they needed some
guitars because a lot of these artist
gears on the truck so there's every
variable was was I mean Leon Bridges was
downstairs being like I'm gonna guess
I'm gonna figure out how to play guitar
again and he's like down there with
Abraham and they're just like rehearsing
like going through like so we're
shuffling all this stuff around
downstairs trying to give them their
space to you know so they can get it
together in rehearse and put on a good
show and yeah man I don't know what
happened but like the sound quality of
everything was great
um yeah I had so I was on vacation
in Colorado for the past 10 days fishing
and had been driving in a car for over
24 hours got to Chattanooga at 10 45 a.m
Sunday
went to sleep woke up I was like I'm
gonna take a shower I'm gonna go eat and
like I knew I had Moon River passes like
I'm just gonna give them to somebody and
make their day because I just need to
relax and chill
and then um look across as I'm coming
out of the shower look across to see
that the phone's going off and it's Ted
I was like oh man I was like hey man
how's it going it's like hey we're gonna
move Moon River to Memorial what do you
think I was like uh do what
I didn't even know it was raining so I
look outside I'm like oh this is bad
um but thank goodness like right before
we had uh before I gone on vacation
Phillips PA was sitting up at Memorial
and there was still some lighting that
was jailed and um right before we left
the guy was like should we take this
down and like get it all put up I was
like you know what let's just I'm going
on vacation let's just leave it you know
so that way if something happens I don't
know the star is really kind of aligned
to make that work that would have been
two and a half hours there's no way we
could have gotten that PA up so the PA
being up and then Philip Jones from PLJ
audio just like absolutely I mean he's
probably the one that saved it more than
anybody like he just I called him was
like I need I need an audio engineer I
need five Ledges I need a an amp rack
can you can you be here in 15 minutes
and he's like
and just threw it together all the time
right yeah he mixed it on the Fly we did
hardly any sound check some people
didn't even show up like Drew's called
me being like we need this there's gonna
be like start out with three people then
it's five people and then it changed you
know Leon showed up people just kept
coming through the door
it was pretty wild it was a really
exciting fun night though
so then Abraham Alexander reaches out to
me on Instagram who he his set did get
to happen early in the day right before
the chaos began yeah I saw a little bit
of his set yeah he was incredible he was
so he basically said uh we had not heard
back from Charlie or Leon's Charlie
Crockett or Leon's people yet had gotten
sort of the the impression that they
were not going to be able to make it
make it work for them and you know
cheers to Abraham because he reached out
to me on Instagram and said hey I'm
coming I'd love to play a couple songs
and help out
and also I'm I'm trying really hard to
get Charlie and Leon to come because
they're all three friends and so
um we got worried about halfway through
the show that that Charlie we got we're
at the beginning of the show that
Charlie was coming and then we got
worried about halfway through the show
that Leon is on his way and uh it was
just an absolutely magical night and the
artists were so gracious to do that and
the fans came in I mean they were lined
up outside the building by the thousands
I don't know how many people it holds in
there but there had to have been 3 000
people in the room yeah 2500 I don't
know but it was uh
definitely like it was incredibly
emotional it was difficult
um it was this weird mixture of
disappointment from the day but also
this unique thing got to happen that was
literally once in a lifetime for
everybody in the room I called Nick
Wilkinson at 603 p.m uh last night
and I said to Nick hey we want to you
know Drew wants to do a Drew Holcomb and
Friends special show with the memorial
can we make this happen I might have
said please you've got to make this
happen and Nick and Nick all Nick said
to me was
you got it
I think he might have said buddy you got
it he says buddy a lot he's just like
you got it and then he's like I gotta go
and he hung up on me yeah and that was
it
pretty much right I mean again I and I
knew that the people who were really in
the trenches like Sam Courtney and all
the folks they had to activate you know
we had to make sure because because we
had been kind of going back and forth we
all gathered up at Memorial what was
that guy's about five or so yeah and we
were all kind of walking through just to
see what what the everything looked like
thankfully the place was in great shape
like Sam said the next equipment was up
I mean we just had it clean I mean it
was really really looked sharp so I was
like well everything looks right here
that was it I was like Nick uh I know I
texted him like we got to do doors at 8
30 and yeah I mean what an amazing
amazing team that they in two hours and
27 minutes were able to assemble a staff
have concessions to sell to people uh
get their ushers in place like it was a
whole different team of people that
memorial memorial uses the Moon River
and they got their team together and
executed the night and I thought I
thought they were just superstars
Ted I I feel like I need to ask this and
I probably should have asked it at the
front uh and we might move it move it
around but because I I know people are
going to want to know what are the sort
of things that go into making that
decision that go no go
uh type of decision and I don't know if
you can answer that in a minute or two
but it's not a it's not easy quickly
it's not I mean it's like
um going back to what Drew was saying
like there there's a group of us who
work on this festival for a year like
today we're already starting to talk
about artists for next year what are we
going to do that's going to make it
better next year
um so it's just really it's devastating
when you're faced with making a call to
not move forward with something you know
for the safety of the fans and the staff
and the artists it's just it's just
really hard it's you know for me it was
a little emotional but at the end of the
day like I thought I I don't I don't
think I know our team made a really hard
call it was painful uh but it was
primarily based on the conditions of the
site
um it was it was flooded in a lot of
areas and a lot of key areas that we
needed to access for both uh you know
for patrons and for Ada Etc
uh and the fact that we were getting a
weather forecast that were predicting
additional storms that would have rain
and and lightning yeah and the site the
site was not able to load those fans
back in
um
and not to be dramatic but I watch a lot
of those Music Festival documentaries
and I had just watched uh both firefest
which is I think a real lesson in what
not to do in life
um and then also like the Woodstock 99
one yeah and I just I just think
sometimes the the the best decision is
the hardest one at the time when you're
gonna have to tell people
who have you know planned on this for
for months and months and just so much
joy coming to Chattanooga to experience
this with Drew and all the artists tell
them you can't do it it's tough yeah but
but when you know you're making the
right decision for the safety of
everybody involved you know you just
think about well what would happen if
you put 5 000 people onto this site and
then at night you can't see where you're
walking we're trying to do the right
thing I think that's the best way to say
it and then to speak to Chattanooga one
of the amazing things is just when
you're in a community
that really wants you
you know the this this whole Community
has embraced this festival and uh you
know I I feel and and the staff feels
very very wanted here in the attitude in
Chattanooga is whatever you need we want
to do it
you know and I think it starts with
having a great mayor like Tim Kelly you
know who's calling me
uh just to ask me what I need in the
middle of everything on Sunday asking
what he can do to help with moving the
show to Memorial
anything I need is what he told me same
with Nick over at the memorial and then
same with Drew and and Paul and and his
team
and so all of a sudden that gets taken
off out from underneath them because of
the weather stuff and
um so we you know uh all of a sudden
it's sort of all hands on deck we're
getting uh everybody over getting
security moved over and taking all the
details of sort of the logistics of how
it pulled off but as we're setting up
we've already I've already so Ellie and
I make our way I pull up at 7 15 to
Memorial
um
and the staff there is working like
crazy to try to set up some monitors and
mics and we're getting as many lines run
as we can and you know it's totally
efficient fishing for a compliment for
Chattanooga but it doesn't happen
everywhere like this does it you don't
get that kind of cooperation
um among so many different partners or
at least not that I've seen
is that overstating
no I don't I don't think it's
overstating at all I mean if you know if
if Drew doesn't
lead the charge on putting this together
because he cares so passionately
about his fans in the Moon River fans
and and their experience if our team
isn't there to really support Drew's
vision and our vision for what we want
this to be and become in Chattanooga if
the city and mayor Kelly uh isn't a
hundred percent all in and supporting
what we're trying to accomplish if Nick
Wilkinson a memorial doesn't want to
work that night or doesn't want to put
the effort into bringing his team in
um
it it doesn't happen like it did
yesterday and and then there were all of
the you know incredible people that are
in each of those teams who had to work
really really hard and extra hard to
pull off something
um that that took a lot of effort so
it's it's really hats off to everybody
for making it happen there's a lot of
things that had to come together like
normally these you know in my experience
a lot of these bands they come in on
their bus they get their however you
know hour before and they leave
uh but these guys were around and uh and
willing to uh wanting not just willing
but they wanted to perform right so I
mean how does all that happen
yeah yeah what I also want us just to to
um acknowledge some of the artists that
weren't able to play had you know some
of these folks once they found out their
set had been canceled
um they made their way back to Atlanta
or Nashville like kevmo was already back
in Nashville by the time because his
show was supposed to be at 3 30. and
that's that's normal right I mean yeah
totally normal that's my point that's
normal I know for sure that other folks
had but still been in town we probably
would have had them they would have you
know gotten up there as well but I think
you know it it also you know
there's some practicalities as well like
the kind of music that plays at Moon
River is you know it's just it's a it's
sort of a song based lineup you know
these are all like
it's not it's not a huge like while a
lot of these acts may have production
this is not a big uh production heavy
lineup it's a it's there is a lot of
production involved but it's mostly
because a lot of people with a lot of
instruments and
um so you know Charlie you get up there
and singing a couple songs in acoustic
guitar is manageable in this sort of
throw and go format and he's willing he
and Leon being willing to do that or
Abraham
um JP me and Ellie I mean all of us were
playing basically solo acoustic sets but
really like Local Natives and Sammy Ray
being willing to jump up there with like
horns and drums and five vocals and and
have no time to sound check absolutely
unheard of I mean this is like the kind
of stuff you do when you're like a brand
new band trying to like play an open mic
night and it's a total cluster all these
bands uh have earned and deserve sort of
a better situation than that but at the
same time I think they also realize the
sort of gravity of
the the gravity of the opportunity that
that all these people you know Ted and I
have talked about many times before
people come to Moon River come to
Chattanooga from all over the country
and so we know that a lot of the people
there they've booked flights to get
there and they've got hotel rooms that
night and they're not doing anything
it's with the show's canceled they have
no plans and so I was inspired in some
part years ago I can't remember what it
was pilgrimage had a really tough year
one year with rain and had to cancel
everything and I remember my a friend of
mine who we all know and love has played
Moon River Brandy Carlisle she pivoted
that night and put on like I think she
did like two or three shows in a small
venue and like basically had an online
sign up if you have a wristband you can
sign up and tried to pull something off
just try to like
you know pick up the pieces make some
you know the old you know make lemonade
out of lemons so
I I think that the spirit of Moon River
Festival is you know it was it was
amazing I I was so prepared for when we
announced I was looking at social media
like this is gonna be a this comment
section is going to be a dumpster fire
and and while we certainly had
detractors I was amazed at how many
people recognized the the complexity
that if anybody on this whole property
wants this Festival to happen more than
me and Ted I did they don't exist
you know we wanted this thing to go on
more than anybody else in the team and
everybody's been so much work security
vendors I mean there's production
there's soap bands there's so many
people have made plans to have this
thing happen and we can't control these
external circumstances and that's just
the nature of outdoor events you know
so to see
the you know
whether like you said earlier whether
it's Memorial or whether it's
um the security staff that put a bunch
of them in the van and drove over to
help Run Security at the venue I mean it
was like just wild to see it all happen
but I think it's the spirit of the
festival hey this is about music this is
about Community this is about this place
and a lot of people worked really hard
to come here as fans let's let's see if
there's anything we can do to salvage
um what is on it was honestly like a
real like my my two o'clock to six
o'clock was about as depressed and sad
as I've been in a long time
um
and it's you know just it's it would
have been easier had it been like a you
know a four hour lighting storm but it
was these like pockets of cash oh yeah
yeah
and so you're just like man you think
we're gonna get to have it and we don't
and then it pours and it's just like all
this
difficult situation and people were
upset and we you know we get that and
trying to do our best like in the fact
that Ted and his team were willing to do
the refunds was just a home run from
from from a sort of
um like Ted said taking care of our
people and in the Moon River crowd you
know while there's always
um
you're always going to get first-timers
and newcomers who are just there because
they like particular acts on the bill
the general Spirit of Moon River is
definitely a unique Vibe and it's a
unique community that comes together and
loves this place loves this kind of
music loves the people and uh you know I
think that's Ellie and I love music we
love what it we love like the audience
is a part of the band in some ways you
know it's like an extension of the
experience that's why people go to live
shows so I think that that Spirit
hopefully sort of
um flows in every direction with
everybody involved I mean I thought Leon
sounded great all of his songs came
across really well as guitar work was
really good
um you know Drew and Ellie are just
great they could have been better people
to host and you know a little pop-up
yeah so that's something Nick you said
to me yesterday when we were on the
phone that uh if Drew and Ellie aren't
there to act as MCS it would have been a
a cluster I mean it's it's it makes Moon
River so unique that you have basically
a hosted event that yeah by doing that
that you know last minute pivot here I
mean if you have if I mean and there's
other great festivals then obviously C3
AC they've been a part of all of them
but I don't know if any of them that
have like you know a host
like Moon River does so so they were
able to step into that role and and kind
of make it seamless and make it seem
like I mean I
I know Drew was obviously saying how
much time and effort they do put into
this and obviously they do but they're
obviously just incredible just talent
and professionals because they could
just jump right in and it almost looked
like they had planned this for about two
months I mean if you were in a tennis
you thought it was like this was like
almost pre-orchestrated or something
[Music]
oh
all right so there you go
um if you stuck through it all the way
to the end I hope I hope you understand
why why taco and I are so interested in
this there's a it's way inside baseball
it's a little bit inside baseball it it
I hope it gives an insight into
the thinking Behind These festivals and
I mean one of the points that Ted makes
is you know they were standing water but
it was going to be even different once
the lights went once the sun went down
you wouldn't be able to see where you're
stepping I hadn't given that a thought
you know I hadn't either yeah yeah and
there's a lot of this that you don't
immediately think about you think oh we
just got to get it open and let people
in yeah like you said I mean there's Ada
there's there's a lot of reasons why
this would have been a bad idea yeah
yeah I've I've been involved in we had a
hundred team baseball tournament once we
got rained out there's a lot of
decisions and a lot of angst you don't
want to cancel it trust me you don't
want to cancel it but oh yeah you
definitely don't there's so many things
you also just don't want to make the
wrong decision and and have consequences
from that that's right so that's still
really pretty cool to me that so many
people and so many things came together
like they did so
all right well I hope you guys enjoyed
that and thank you we're next show we're
gonna have the interview with why um
wild rivers and uh
Taco you pointed out before we got on
here today that uh rumor season is is
kind of kind of keep catching up too
it's kind of creeping up I mean if you
look at the calendar we're not uh but a
few months away from well January which
is when the lineup comes out so usually
about this time
yeah you start getting um Whispers of
you know bands that might have a gap in
their tour dates around that time and
you know hopefully Brad can be on the
next show because he's probably got more
inside contacts to uh to talk about what
you know what he's hearing well I'm
curious to see we know who he wants
right I mean we have that in yes we have
that in very clear
terms I don't think there's any doubt on
who he wants so yeah he's made his
demands yeah he made his List of Demands
very clear so we'll see how that works
out but uh I haven't given it much
thought as I never do
um not like he does and some other
people but I do know it's a it's time so
that'll we'll have the like I said the
wild rivers and then we'll probably
start talking about that and and he's
got a yeah and go ahead
oh well I was just gonna say you know
we're still healing from the previous
two years of lineups that were announced
and then changed and then canceled and
so it's it takes time to get excited
again because you don't want to get that
feeling of disappointment again when it
doesn't happen but yeah I'm starting to
get excited again uh yeah I know isn't
it funny how it's like well it's like
anything surgery childbirth whatever
your your brain tends to forget how
painful but yeah we kind of mentioned uh
not that I've had childbirth let's be
clear I don't know what that's like I
just heard
um but we kind of tiptoed around it
right at the end of uh I think that show
back in August
um that the lineup this year at Bonnaroo
needs to it needs to be pretty strong
um absolutely yeah I think that's the
key is is to get people back to you know
get it back to the festival back to
those levels of you know where they're
selling out and people are excited and
people want to go because it's all about
the lineup it's the lineup for nothing
it well that and and uh and the the uh
the uh experience that's why I think the
Moon River thing was worth us talking
about because like I said that was it
was a bad deal you know nobody wants to
cancel that but they handled it right
they did not everybody went but they
still handled it right I haven't heard
too many negatives so
you know and again it's some of the same
people so hopefully we've
we've turned that corner of the last
three years which you know I don't know
who to I don't know if there's blame for
any of that it's just the way it
happened with a pandemic and a flow I
mean a hurricane you know who sees that
coming
so exactly it was just a bad collection
of events yep all right so that's it I
think that's it um hopefully you know we
what we presented was the edited down
version of those two conversations
um why don't maybe we'll just put the
full conversation on YouTube maybe just
as an exclusive so if you want to hear
more if you liked it want to check it
out then you can go uh listen to the
full thing but hopefully we gave it a
good concise uh presentation there's a
little bit more in this episode with a
little bit more in there
um yeah glad to do it all right Taco
have a great weekend great week see you
soon and uh thanks again for being so
flexible and being able to jump on and I
enjoyed hanging there last weekend it
was fun me too it was fun to hang out
again even though it was cut cut a
little short yeah I was cut it was fun
as we said on the last show of seeing
some of our Bonnaroo family with the
Charlotte and Daniel and Lindsay it's
always yeah it was almost like a
rhinestone a mini Reunion yeah right
yeah Brian Stone who is by the way right
now he's uh he's on his way to that
Pearl Jam concert didn't he I I have no
idea what he's doing but then I think so
wow oh yeah yeah the one he bought two
sets of tickets for two years ago and
he's
yeah it was supposed to be like his
birthday weekend two years ago and then
of course it got canceled and postponed
and now it's finally happening so he's
good for him he's he's kind of a big
Pearl Jam fan we know that so I I hope
it it won't be I started to say I hope
it exceeds his expectation and hope but
it won't be there's no way it won't
can't wait to hear from you all right
well thank you guys thanks for listening
and uh we'll talk soon
[Music]
consequence podcast Network